bindi Irwin is victorious first night on  Dancing with the Stars my mom always  said that anytime dad would watch me  dance around Missouri that he would cry  I think that the real reason I'm doing  this is to make him proud I think that  everyone gives the older side to bindi  the 17 year old tied Nick Carter for the  highest score of premiere night a 24 out  of 30 for her jive to Elton John's  Crocodile Rock an obvious nod to her  late famous father Steve Irwin  [Music]  other standout contestants included  married couple Carlos Pena Vega and  Alexa Pena Vega Alek skarlatos and tamar  braxton on the flip side reality star  Kim Zolciak